Speaker 1: Let's speak next to how about Alex
from Fairfax, Virginia.
Speaker 2: Either can you hear me, David?
Yes, I can. Hi, David. Well, I'm a relatively
new listener, and I really like your content,
I agree with a lot with a lot what you're
saying, but I'm also a very socially conservative
person. OK, and this is something that is
something that you talk about. But I was wondering
what your take on abortion is. I know that
you were generally pro-choice, and I was wondering
if I could just take like 30 seconds to tell
you what I believe about that and see what
get your thoughts on that. Is that right?
Sure, yeah. So to me, I think, you know, once
someone once an egg is fertilized in the womb,
that's when your unique DNA comes out,
Speaker 1: comes out of where you
Speaker 2: need. And so hold
Speaker 1: on a second. Wait a second. Wait,
wait, wait, wait. You said that when an egg
is fertilized, your unique DNA comes out.
What do you mean by that?
Speaker 2: So the everyone has their own unique
DNA and the and no one, unless they're identical
twins, everyone's DNA is unique. And the thing
that and that's the thing that makes you you
you know, your your body, everything about
you, OK? And that originates at the time of
conception is what I'm trying to say. Sorry
if I wasn't clear. That was what I was trying
to say. That's OK. That originates. And so
from that point on, you know, the only thing
different from like the fertilized egg to
nine months in the womb or baby is just time,
really. And so I feel like at that point from
conception, that's when a human life really
begins, the one that they should have rights.
At that point, though, I think about that.
Speaker 1: Let's explore that. So by analogy,
it sounds like you're saying that if I plant
a cucumber seed today and it germinate, meaning
at that point it has germinated, it has gone
beyond being just the seed. It is no longer
just a sperm cell right under. You know, the
analogy I'm using here,
Speaker 2: I think I'm following OK, I have
no analogy, but
Speaker 1: the day of germination of my cucumber
seed, the only difference between that and
five months later when I have a full plant
with a dozen cucumbers that I can eat on it,
the only difference is time. Would you agree
with that?
Speaker 2: I mean, so long as we don't mess
with, like, normal processes that happen,
I mean, we have to make sure the ground is
water and make sure is I mean, I get with
analogies going, I wouldn't say. Right. So
I guess I guess my question is. Yeah, but
I would generally agree. I would generally
agree with maybe a little caveat, but. Sure.
Speaker 1: So would. So by your by your statement
about the day of the, you know, the first
day of conception and nine months later, the
only difference this time a one day germinated
cucumber seed is no different than a plant
with 12 cucumbers that you could eat. And
so would you treat both of those with the
same care and in the exact same way?
Speaker 2: I wouldn't say that they're exactly
the same, but when it comes in the specific
context of like a baby in the womb, though,
unlike a a cucumber, I do believe when it
comes to human life, I think we're talking
about like rights. When you're saying about
treating them the same way, I believe that
there are there are rights that need to be
recognized right now.
Speaker 1: But I'm not saying that treating
I'm not saying treating Cucumber's and humans
the same way. What I'm saying is your understand
would you relate to a one day germinated cucumber
seed the same way you would relate to a cucumber
plant with 12 edible cucumbers on it?
Speaker 2: Not a cucumber, no, no.
Speaker 1: So then why would it be the exact
same thing with humans?
Speaker 2: Because generally relate to humans
differently than we do with cucumbers.
Speaker 1: OK, but I think the point becomes,
at what point do we say that legally we should
be dealing with them in the same way? And
the science, no science that I've seen. I
mean, philosophically and conceptually, what
you're saying about the day of conception
might resonate with you, but scientifically,
I've seen nothing that says that what's there
on the day of conception is anything like
what's there at nine months, never mind after
the second trimester, never mind after the
first trimester. So I guess the question would
be say you might feel as though these are
equivalent things, but there's no science.
I've seen that says that they are.
Speaker 2: And is there like just to make
sure I'm not quite sure what you're saying,
so is there. Can you give an example of what
type of evidence would you need to convince
you on a science basis that there would be
similar things or just
Speaker 1: different doctors have different
views. Some are talking about at a certain
point of neurological development. Others
talk about when would when would the fetus
be viable outside of the womb? I mean, I think
we have to go to science and medical science
with that question. I don't know that you
and I will sort of sort that out.
Speaker 2: Yeah, sure, so I understand your.
So just to make sure I understand what you're
saying from your perspective, just because
the jury's still out on the scientific point
of view, the experts are still arguing about
it. You don't feel the need to take a stand.
It's not that the experts
Speaker 1: are arguing about it. It's that
there's no medical perspective. I've read
that says the day of conception, you have
something that we would logically assign rights
or personhood to. The debate seems to be much
narrower at a much later period of the pregnancy,
sort of like where most Americans believe
abortion should be legal. In most cases. The
debate around conception for me is a false
debate. It's an arbitrarily extreme debate
because very few people even think that that's
a debate worth having. The debate really is
about late term abortion. And and, you know,
only the most extreme religious conservatives
or social conservatives are talking about
conception. So I don't even engage in the
debate, really, because it's just it's not
where the science is and it's not where society
is.
Speaker 2: OK, David. Well, if that if that's
your perspective, I understand I appreciate
your content. Thank you for everything. One
last thing I just want to clear up on. You
said that the science hasn't gone to a point
where we don't know if we should assign rights
to them or not. I didn't
Speaker 1: say that. What I said is there
is no case I've seen made that is a science
or or medical case that justifies personhood
and rights for cells a day after conception.
Speaker 2: OK, thank you for clearing that
up, David. I appreciate your perspective,
I appreciate what you do. And it was a pleasure
talking to you.
Speaker 1: The pleasure is all mine. Thank
you very much. Very, very good. OK, it's I
mean, it's a little surprising. People still
want a debate at conception. I didn't even
think anybody was debating that anymore. But.
But people are people are let's go next to
why don't we go to William from Minnesota.
William, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: Well, David, can you hear me? Yes,
I can. I was just hoping to pick your brain
a little bit about, oh,
Speaker 1: I have to admit, whenever I'm at
a dinner party and someone says they want
to pick my brain, I try to head for the hills.
That's a big red flag that things are going
Speaker 2: to go bad. Is that the saying?
Speaker 1: It's a bad. Yeah, that's a that's
that's a dinner party. Red flag. Let's see
if we can recover from it, though.
Speaker 2: I was hoping to hear your perspective
on an untapped reservoir beautifully of funds,
building and reaching out to new audiences
when it comes to politics, specifically when
it comes to different streaming platforms
such as Twitter and YouTube. OK, it seems
like both political parties just seem to have
this aversion to. Branching out into the new
generation of media, specifically when I talk
about this and thinking about the different
fundraising that can come from these different
platforms, such as, say, for Twitch Pastilla,
an Australian gamer, the primarily stream
escape from Tarkoff raised one point two million
Australian dollars for a children's fundraiser
for children with cancer. OK, let's see if
I can give you another example. An example,
Dr Lupo. Well, I know what point what was
your
Speaker 1: what was your question? People
people do fundraisers and they raise money
through their platforms. Give it. Given that,
what was your question?
Speaker 2: Given that, why does it seem like
with these numbers that the political parties
and these different political actors seem
to not respect that as a way to move forward
politically, politically?
Speaker 1: You're saying political actors
don't respect fundraising as a way or twitch
fundraising as a way to move forward?
Speaker 2: I wanted to expand on my point,
but having been cut off, it seems like these
people can reach such massive audiences and
these fundraisers can then huge amounts of
cash. It seems like there's just not the will
to move forward to use both Twitter and YouTube
streaming and the audiences that come along
with them to build a little political career.
And I don't understand why
Speaker 1: to build a career. So you're saying
someone who wants to be a candidate, who does
fundraising on YouTube and twitch rather than
doing the things candidates might normally
do?
Speaker 2: Or even alongside them, not necessarily
in spite of what other candidates may normally
do?
Speaker 1: Oh, I think I see candidates do
that. I mean, I've seen, you know, particularly
in the era of the pandemic zum fundraiser's
and livestream fundraisers. I think I do see
it. Maybe it's just not being done as much
or it's not as sophisticated yet. I also recall
Congresswoman Alexandrea Castillo Cortez doing
live streaming, playing games and doing major
fundraisers for causes that she cares about.
So I think it is being done to some degree.
Speaker 2: OK, and just as a follow up question,
I was wondering your thoughts on the validity
of this when it comes to moving forward in
the political climate that we see?
Speaker 1: I think it's completely valid and
I think it's absolutely fine, assuming it
doesn't break any campaign finance law.
Speaker 2: I think that that's a perfectly
nice perspective. Thank you very
Speaker 1: much. All right, thanks, William.
There is William from Minnesota. We're going
to take a quick break. If you're holding,
don't hang up, because we're going right back
to the phones momentarily